麻烦家伙。
麻烦家伙，我说周星驰那些片子啊呃基本都是小人物摊上啊大事儿，小人物摊上大事儿。
小蝌蚪找妈妈。
给他放进去。
几个元素如辜，就说这个主人公要人畜无害呀。
越善良越好。
呃，破坏之王里面星仔。
多可爱呀。
对吧又可爱又善良送外卖，而且先天的乐天派，所有人都欺泡他他没感觉，他觉得很好呀，很开心呀。乐天派啊。
然后突然天降。
灾祸。
改变了呃他的生活轨迹，让他面临生死考验。
就前面做的越越人畜无害越好，那我们就把它做成一只天真无邪的小蝌蚪。
天真无邪的小蝌蚪呀。
生活在妈妈身边，妈妈对她保护的很好。
他甚至有点傻白甜。
这要保护的很好嘛，无忧无虑啊，就等着快乐的，等着长大就好了。
突然。
天降灾祸。
他妈的，比如说。
他妈被。
被牛蛙店给抓走了，被一个饭店，一个川菜馆子。
给抓走了，在一笼子里面。
王走了。
第溜走了。
天降，这是天降灾祸呀。
他现在要。
小蝌蚪要找妈妈。
就是要去那个川菜馆去把妈妈营救出来。
生死考验。
你去到那个川菜馆，对吧？你怎么过去地下这个下水道这个线路。
是吧你几点去？
几点他们打烊，然后怎么样冲到水族箱，然后水族箱里还有咬人的王八，别你说。
面临生死考验，怎么样把妈妈营救出来？
一个傻白甜的小蝌蚪。
降临到这么大的一个任务。
这种片子啊一般是讲主角的成长。
就他前面很无辜很弱小嘛。
所以这种片子一般都有个训练过程。
你看周星驰片子今天有个训练过程，对吧？那个无敌风火轮之类的，所以他也需要有点刻工片的那种感觉。
训练自己的各种能力。
训练自己憋气，对吧？
脱离水能奔多远？
能能不能奔进去，对吧？然后要要那个那个那个钻下水道。
要爬玻璃，怎么样从那个水族箱的玻璃上一步一步的扭上去，对吧？他要在河边的那个长满青苔的很滑的石头上练模拟那个玻璃。
就是特工训练的那一套。
对吧如何用这个现有的材料给自己制作一个保护色的外套？
对吧谁训练它？
对吧这个这个这我们说千年王八万年归呀，这个池塘里最资深最见多识广的就是一只老王八。这个老王八就是达叔呀，达叔说对吧？要想跟断水流大兄打，你要练成无敌风火轮，这个王八就要教他一些特工技巧，因为这个王八是吃过见过的。
而且这个王八有个什么人生经历呢？他曾经进过这个川菜馆，成功逃脱出来。
他是等于那就不要了。那这样。
这个天降就是他们生活的这个池塘，他以为是个池塘。
他跳出去之后，发现这就是个养殖场。
明白这个意思吗？这就是个养殖场。
等于这个王八就是。
曾经被捞进去过，然后他从下水道里溜出来了。
但是下水道里因为。
那个川菜馆那个火锅那些油热油往下水倒里倒，给他烫瞎了双眼。
他还是摸哈回来。
所以他现在。
也办残了，不能直接带着你去，只能教你，凭着记忆教你。
那这就是一个。
麻烦家伙，一个无辜的小蝌蚪，妈妈被抓走了，对吧？他要从这个养殖场的池塘去到。
去到前面前院。
那个那个饭店那里川菜馆。
把妈妈救出来，小蝌蚪找妈妈。
这就是。
烦家伙行啊。
很符合吧。
我们说变签仪式。
变签仪式。
编捷仪式名字很难很很拗口，很不容易理解。我们说一下定义就知道，就是一个普通的生活问题。
一个常见的生活里面的问题。
你没有用正常的方式去处理。
导致了一系列的后果，你要么过激的处理了，你要么逃避的去处理了。总之你没有正面的去面对。
导致了一系列的后果。然后最后的结局呢，你回归到正确的解决方式上，这就是变迁意识。这类片子呢一般很写实的。
很生活的。
我们举过例子那触不可及，对吧？一个瘫痪的人，他他他他想放弃放弃生命，所以他他找了一个不靠谱的。
呃，看护不靠谱的保姆啊，男保姆。
但是恰恰是这个不靠谱的男保姆。
很不靠谱。
很不按常理出牌，反而。
让他回归了，觉得。
活着也挺好的，瘫痪就瘫痪了。
瘫化了一样可以有乐趣，一样可以有有价值，一样可以有爱情。
是吧。
这就是。
变迁意识性。
这是触不可及。
那我们反过来看小蝌蚪找妈妈。
要变成意识。
小蝌蚪找妈妈。
要变迁意次。
他的问题他的问题，我们说问题必须是一个很生活化的，大家都能理解。
甚至都会遇到的问题。
既然叫小蝌蚪找妈妈，那就是母子关系呗。
好不好？
那就是母子关系嘛。
母子关系。
是小蝌蚪的问题。
然后他采取了一种过激的行为。
比如说。
离家出走了。
走了。
不要这个妈了。
那最后的结局肯定是回归家庭。
觉得世上只有妈妈好。
那为了增加戏剧性啊。
他这个过激离开。
他这个母子关系问题啊。
我们直接给他弄成。
养母。
那这个问题上来就会更激烈。
就小蝌蚪到了青春期。
跟自己的养母。
越来越。
冒合神利。
越来越不对不对付。
他坑他的养母，对吧？儿子和养母的关系嘛。
来。
首先。
我。
到青春期了。
尾巴什么的都开始收起来，开始长四肢了。
但是。
我们并没有长成我妈妈的样子呀。
我妈妈有壳。
我没有。
对吧我软的。
他妈妈是个王八。
80元青蛙。
它没有壳儿，然后呢，他慢慢的就感受到了。
社会上的。
风言风语。
以前小又不懂事了，对吧？就觉得世上只有妈妈好。
现在到了青春期，本来就是一个叛逆的年龄，本来就是一个要个性的年龄。
然后。
他发现。
我跟妈妈为什么差别这么大？
然后就就。
就去问他妈。
他妈呢可能是出于。
对他的爱，对他的保护，没有和盘托出所有的事情。
导致母子之间。
有矛盾，有问题。
就他跟他的母亲有问题了呀。
是。
你如果一个你设想一个小孩，在青春期发现自己不是亲生的。
你肯定你的第一反应就是想我我是哪来的？
你要告诉我。
对吧你养我到15岁没问题，你要告诉我我是从哪来的，你是捡的还是要的，还是买的，你要告诉我。
他妈妈呢。
支支吾吾回避这个问题，他显然就会造就这个问题啊。再加上生活上生活习惯差异越来越大，对吧？他呢伸舌头吃东西，让他找东西吃，他妈的探头，在那看越看越不顺眼，看什么炭是吧？物种不一样的？
等于是。
面对这样一个正常的家庭关系。
母子问题，母子矛盾。
他采取了过激的行为。
他离家出走，离家出走有目标啊，我要去找我亲妈，我要找我的种族。
找我的属于我的。
我的种族。
然后在一系列。
这个这个。
折腾对吧？冲去找。
遇到这个危险。
呃，遇到一点路上，在青春期嘛，肯定大家再遇到点爱情。
然后去找到这个这个挖群。
对吧。
最后在挖群里面。
这个融入生活。
嗯，找到一些爱。
获得一些短暂的那叫虚假胜利嘛，在挖群里面获得一些虚假胜利。比如说爱情，比如说有人对他挺好。
但是。
最后回归认为。
外表的相似。
不如心连的心好。
什么也没有把你养大的人。
跟你的感情深。
再回到家庭。
在这个。
熏闹的过程中。
理解自己的。
母亲。
理解自己的养母。
你如果想做的极致一点，就可以让他知道。
比如说当年的故事。
对吧让他通过一些侧面知道当年的故事。
当年自己小时候。
是怎么被？
王八给养大的。
是吧。
这就是一个。
变签仪式型的片子，这种片子就不会很喜剧了。
也不会很动作。
就会很很很写实，甚至可以做的偏沉重。
你可以做的偏感人啊这种片子。
可以让人哭的这种片子。
就是。
你的牙母。
对吧。
他当年。
你知道他经历了什么吗？
他的一窝王八蛋哎，不是一窝王八卵，他的一窝王八卵。
都被蛇给掏了，或者被被被被水塔给掏了。
对吧然后呢。
你呢？
你妈妈在那次浩劫中，你失去了妈妈，他失去了所有的蛋。
他拼死保护着你。
自己受了重伤，拼死保护着你。
才把救下了你。
然后跟你相依为命。
你说说你还对吧？你还在这儿。
跟养母还还不听话。
那么不懂事呢？就这种片子是可以做的比较揪心的。
想想办法有很多办法啊，我们说愚者成功。
我们说这个变迁仪式啊，仪式变迁类的这种片子啊，一般是偏沉重的，愚者成功啊。
喜剧片的面儿就大。
因为是个傻子嘛。
傻子面临一个。
他融入不进去的，我他这个这个书上说叫伟业，一个伟大的事业，就是一个傻子去干一件伟大的事业。然后在这个过程中经历一些虚假的变化。啥叫虚假的变化？就是他要刻意的营造自己可以融入进去？就是丑小鸭。
刻意的。
半半成天鹅融入进去，最后反而觉得你好好做鸭也行。
那对于这个小蝌蚪的片子，做起来也很容易啊。
一只干憨憨的。
小蝌蚪小蝌蚪做的傻乎乎的很容易的。一个小黑点嘛，铁憨憨。
很傻。
然后呢，假设这个小蝌蚪生活在一个水上这那个水族馆吧，一个水族馆。
小蝌蚪。
在这个这个这个呃水族馆的。
户外池塘里。
天天看着这个水族馆人来人往，小那个小朋友都会去啊，好漂亮啊，去看观赏鱼。
观赏鱼那个那个水族厅的很呃小朋友很喜欢。然后这个港憨憨的小蝌蚪就是这个渔者。
他立志想当一只观赏鱼。
然后呢。
他就。
通过一次。
巧合也好。
偶然的一个钻了一个空子也好。
进到了观赏鱼鱼缸。
比如说全是那种很漂亮的那种小翅膀的，小金鱼也行，很漂亮的观赏鱼，一屋子。
愚者。
小蝌蚪进入了观赏鱼的。
鱼缸。
开始去适应观赏鱼的生活，学人家游泳的姿势，学人家那个呃吐泡泡的方式，学人家怎么跟小朋友们互动，怎么样要零食吃，就一直在融融入进去。
当然要给他制造障碍啊，这个观赏鱼鱼池观赏鱼里面有老大，这老大是不接受他的，懂吗？但是他又努用自己一股傻劲儿。
去不断的重复的训练，不断的呃人家做10次，他做1000次那种，他就是。
这个观赏鱼缸里面的许三多呀。
明白这个意思吗？
他就是这个观赏鱼缸里面的许三多，不是金鱼，硬要当金鱼，对吧？我他妈是黑不溜秋一根小尾巴，我练我也要给他练分叉了。
对吧我就要当金鱼，所以它就是。
呃，在这个鱼者这个这个小小蝌蚪在这个观赏鱼的鱼缸里面。
奋力打拼自己的事业，立志成为一名优秀的舞蹈演员。
这观赏鱼都啊都是跳舞的呀。
对吧他节食不敢多吃是吧？然后呢拼命的练自己的尾巴，让自己的尾巴更灵活。
对吧然后拼命的这个这个吐泡泡，拼命的增加自己的游游泳的速度。
虚假的一些变化，就是这伪装自己，终于可以跟上。
这些金鱼的队伍啦，巡游啊，这观赏鱼群游是实狮这个水族馆小朋友们最喜欢看的一个项目。
然后终于有一天到了群游的一那天，然后这个观赏鱼缸里面的总教头，那只小丑鱼说。
点点。
今天。
你也上不去表演。
欣喜若狂呀。
虚假的变化呀，欣喜若狂呀，终于得到认可了。总教头都认可我许散多了。
懂我这意思吧？我虽然是一个蝌蚪，但我命由我不由天，我就是要当金鱼，就是要当观赏鱼。
终于到这一天了，来吧，盛大的表演提前一天晚上激动的睡不着觉。第二天想想无数的小朋友在外面为我欢呼，为我呐喊，我是一只金鱼，对吧？然后想想想想就兴奋，这天晚上激动的睡不着觉啊，浑身亢奋，荷尔蒙迸发，然后到了第二天，虽然他排在最后一个，但是终于也进到这个队伍了。
看着前面的各个小姐姐们，那些啊那些舞蹈演员就这哈啦哈啦哈啦戳就全部像像那个阅兵式一样就弹出去了，冲冲冲冲到塌了，他就觉得我练练到现在终于该往上场了，靠喊。
一看哎。
我尾巴呢？
养兵千日用在一时，我尾巴哈。
一使劲儿哎，我怎么这么有了？
我到底哎，这这哎，我这是怎么回事？
对吧。
一个晚上没睡觉。
第二，竞征出现了。
尾巴没了，腿出来了。
你是个蛤蟆，还终究是个蛤蟆。
一切都是虚假的。
然后他跟在那个拼命的跟在那个鱼鱼群的后面，哎呀，哎人家都在那表演舞蹈，表演这个是吧？排练好的各种民族舞。
他在后面啊呀，终于等到机会，结果是这番丑态。
结果是这番丑态。
做回自己。
你就是你。
你不用非又非要去。
成就别人的伟业，但是它的主题是什么呢？成就自己的伟业。
就是小朋友们啊。
反而最喜欢他。
为他鼓掌，为他喝彩。
他有他自己的精彩呀，谁说四条腿有。
啊，就不好看呢。
谁说这样就不帅呢？
他完全可以。
他一样可以窜出水面。
对吧。
它还可以一下蹦到这个玻璃墙壁上一蹬再弹回来，它可以做别的特技动作。
观赏鱼做不了的特技动作，小朋友们没有看过的特技动作。
所以他在开始难受，尴尬丢脸。
到慢慢的发现小孩子们在笑，并不是嘲笑，是开心的笑。
游着游着游出了自信，游出了洒脱。
甚至从排尾。
总教徒让他上去是，让他跟在后面的。
成为05啦。
他的领头大，其他的鱼群跟着它游了。
因为现场气氛嗨起来了，对吧？
他他在前面游了，姐妹们别害臊，别害臊，我跟你说啊，岁数都不小了，别害臊。
是吧他这这就这就搞起来了，这就是标准的愚者成功，就是丑小鸭反而成为了最美的天鹅。
你虽然还是丑小鸭，不用概变自己，你就是最美的。
好吧，你看愚热成功，这不就把小蝌蚪找妈妈做成喜剧片了吗？
被制度化。
我们说被制度化需要有一个群体。
就是有一个群体的行为模式。
然后我们的个体呢是其中的。
1元。
但是。
他面临了选择。
到底是。
做自己。
还是做群体的一员，屈从于群体。
然后在这个抗争中做出牺牲。
这种片子。
哎，普遍都是比较。
沉重严肃了那个教父。
飞跃疯人院，最后呢那那个那个飞跃疯人院，最后呢变傻了嘛，被人抓回来把把那个切掉之后变傻了嘛。
那么这个小蝌蚪找妈妈，我们也。
可以。
想想办法。
这里我们可以设的沉重一点。
比如说。
这些小蝌蚪。
小蝌蚪群体，一群小蝌蚪。
他们生活在一个轮胎印儿里。
就是下完雨之后，那个轮胎压的那个大大轮胎压的那个印儿，一个脏水坑，生活着一群一一群。
这个小蝌蚪。
他们是一个标准的一个群体。
然后呢，他们什么都没有见过，这是他们的全部世界。
也是全部人生。
他们就在这里机械的在这里找东西吃，在这里游水其实在一直在变少，就在这里等自己的命运。
等自己的命运。
加一个外部威胁，比如说有一只猫。
猫是吃蝌蚪物。
有一只猫。
每一天都过来吃掉五六只小蝌蚪。
所有人都都麻木了，都会觉得这小蝌蚪挤成一排都挤在这儿。
都觉得。
每天。
要被吃掉5个，每天要被吃掉5个，这是一种规矩，这是一种社会规则。
对吧猫就是比我们更上一层的。
这个这个阶层阶级，我们呢就属于这个水坑，我们就是要一个挤一个，因为水越来越少，他们全部挤在一块，见过那种水坑里面的呃蝌蚪吗？密密麻麻挤成一排。
他们觉得这就是我们的全部人生，我们就是活该这样。
对吧。
这就是就是这样喽，这是规矩啊。
每天来吃5个，每天来吃5个，只要我不是那5个就可以。我们这么多呢。
只要我不是那5个就可以。
就大家一直在这里。
只要就每个人都在侥幸的活着。
麻木的活着。
都会觉得我们这里有上千个小蝌蚪，每天吃5个。
说不定。
吃到我的概率不大。
就是在这样一个坑里。
一个麻木的群体。
大家都是韭菜。
等着被割。
我们的这个点点。
我们就点歌我们点歌啊点歌在这个群体里面。
他比较有脑子。
他比较擅长思考。
他就提出来了。
我们真的就没有其他选择了吗？
我们为什么要被那只猫吃？它是干嘛的？我们是谁？我们是干嘛的？我们来到这个世上。
难道就是别人的点心吗？
我就不服这种制度。
我不同意。
我就想知道为什么。
他也不是说一上来就是那种大彻大悟，想要抗争，想要反抗，他就是不服。
不分儿。
他觉得凭什么？
所以他开始不安分了。
他开始号召。
这些。
小蝌蚪。
说我们可以可以想了想办法。
对吧我们可以会想想办法，比如我看。
我感觉。
我们东边我们这个车轮胎这个印儿往往东边这里。
这个泥土发软，我们可不可以都往这边钻？
尝氏能不能有别的发现？实际上东边确实有一个池塘，明白我意思吗？
所以他的感觉是对的，他就感觉东边啊就这种动物它是有本能的，就哪边有水，它是有本能的。他说我就感觉东边啊是有松动，我们向着东方努一努。
但是其他的小蝌蚪。
没有人听他的，他就觉得我们认命呀，每天吃5个，每天吃5个又吃不到，我又吃不到你。
迟到了认命了。
就没有人听他的。
然后他要做出选择，他是坚持自我还是随大流？
他选择了坚持自我。
他去东边钻。
但是坚持自我是有个代价的。
你一个人去东边钻，其他人就在西边挤着。那么个冒过来的时候啊，你最危险。
对吧。
你你最危险，你暴暴露了呀。
但是他还是在坚持，他一个人在对抗。
直到他的这个真诚。
他的这些。
特立独行的这些做法。
慢慢的感化这个群体当中。
有一些。
有的是。
嗯。
稍微能听得懂人话的，还有一些是。
比如说他有小弟。
就觉得我哥干嘛我干嘛，对吧？还有比原本是他的仇家，一样也有脑子的。
然后也被他的精神感动，就他在这个群体里慢慢。
有了影响力。
有一伙小队伍开始往东面钻。
等于这个。
这个这个工程的进度加快。
东边这个泥土慢慢的钻开一块，钻开一块钻开一块。
马上就要跟。
那个河水。
贯通了。
就在这一刻。
对吧马上就要成功的这一刻。
一个拖拉机开过来。
他们比如说牺牲掉一半。
牺牲掉一半。
这个计划。
完全破产。
然后这又打下去了嘛。
正当万念俱灰的时候。
天降大雨。
就所有人都嘲笑他，傻了吧，不让你去钻，不让你去钻，还把你弟弟害死了。你看你弟弟。
压扁了。
都爆了爆炸了。
是不是？
你看你干的好事儿。
所有人都不理解他，认为他害了我们。
的时候。
一场大雨。
这个水坑填平灌满所有的小蝌蚪。
都冲到了河里。
得到了真正的自由。
得到了真正的自。
他的坚持。
他对制度的对抗。
他的抗争是对的。
然后等所有的小蝌蚪都进到池塘里，安全健康的生活，再也不用担心那只猫的时候。
雨停了，水位在慢慢下去的时候，所有人都发现。
所有人都在说。
前天老去。
水位又下去了。
池塘还是那个池塘，水坑还是那个水坑。
点点还在水坑里。
他没出来。
因为他弟弟死在那儿了。
他兄弟死在那儿了。
他抗争这个制度，对抗这个群体。
最高的目标并不是活命。
明白我这个意思吧？他可能最初是为了活命。
但是点点对抗这个水坑，对抗那只猫。
他只想证明对抗的价值。
他只想告诉你，不用不要放弃希望。
他只想告诉你努力会有结果。
他这个目的达到了。
有我们有希望了，大家都活下去了，我的目的达到了我我的坚持是对的。
我并不是为了活命，所以我没走。
因为我弟弟在这儿。
我兄弟在这儿，他们死在这儿了。
我也死在这。
这就是。
被制度化。
点点我们的。
小蝌蚪。
找妈妈。
十个类型的故事。
吃个小蝌蚪找妈妈。
下课。